[Music]
so the Halo franchise originated for us
back in 2000 we had decided to do the
Xbox project and we were out looking for
games that Microsoft could publish on
Xbox because as the creator of the
console we had to have our own games and
there was this group called Bungie that
had this game called halo that was in
development started on the Macintosh
ironically got moved to the PC and so
when we saw them it was a PC game and
the guy who found it on the team was a
guy named ed fries who ran our first
party game studio and it came to me and
said hey we have this acquisition I
think this game is a winner and it's you
know it's a it's not a small acquisition
but it's not a large acquisition let's
do it
so we looked at and we did and so I
didn't play a big role in doing that but
now we own it and now we have to house
the Bungie team and they're a creative
team and they're not gonna work in
offices they're gonna work in an open
space and we have to restructure the
building to enable them to get their
work done and then we get to that first
e3 in 2001 which was just cataclysmic
for us and halo looked awful and it
played awful and IDI did something very
smart and the Bungie team did something
very smart they pulled back and said
nobody gets to touch halo we're not
gonna let people play it the team's
going into hibernation you know close
the door we're gonna make this a great
game and three months later it was
amazing and so what really happened in
that three-month period is that they
narrowed it and they had a great game
concept they had a great gameplay
dynamic but they narrowed in on
optimizing how the hard work and the
game worked together to produce a great
experience and because they weren't
spending time doing demos and doing
press meetings and trying to convince
people as a great game they could really
focus on it make it happen
and they created a unique dynamic in
that period I think one of the things
that made halo resonate wow there's
really two things the first is it was a
great story by itself it was a great
story and in fact there's been books
there's a whole series of Halo books and
I've read three of them and they're
actually quite good video game books
generally as
it's not the most powerful literary area
these are good books they're interesting
they're challenging and so the story was
great so it's a single-player game
people enjoyed it there's a fascinating
story the second thing is it was a
community game it was a game that was
about playing with others and in the
console world that just didn't exist
they were multiplayer games sure but
halo started this whole idea of they
were going to get eight people together
and we're gonna have a Halo fest at
night and in the original people forget
that the original version of Xbox Xbox
Live didn't exist for the first year and
in fact the first version of Halo never
supported Xbox Live and so you had to
wire your Xboxes together so literally
people would bring four X boxes to a
house they'd go in four different rooms
of the house late ethernet cable in the
house and play Halo all night because it
was so much fun to play against each
other and to play with other people so
the idea of being a great single-player
story and a great multiplayer game was a
winning strategy and when that product
came out
it saved Xbox without Halo and Xbox Live
Xbox doesn't survive it gets lots of
credit as being a gate great game
franchise and not enough credit as being
one of the two reasons why Xbox was
successful
you
[Music]